have you thought of using the film as a
calling card to maybe pitch yourselves
to a network on your own show we have
actually someone else actually started
presented that idea to us which I think
could be really interesting you know but
we right now I think our focus is so
much on sort of this documentary in this
project that we haven't necessarily
thought about it and in terms of that
yeah she can't she this particular
person came from a television background
and thought it would be really great and
we agree but I think yeah we want to
finish this first and also we love tiny
houses and loved making one but you know
we're also filmmakers primarily and are
interested in all sorts of different
types of stories so you know if it
happens that would be great but I think
that we're also perfectly happy
exploring these other interests that we
have you know for our next projects that
will see are you more happy being behind
the camera in front yeah it is I mean I
think um I mean definitely sort of being
a writer you know it's a similar process
of sort of like being behind the scenes
and observing stuff and then thinking
about how can i shape what I've observed
to tell a story you know and I mean I
think I'm definitely sort of like a more
behind the camera personality I think
but I mean Christopher you know saying
in a few bands and stuff like that so
he's you know yeah I used to do it no no
I don't know how to discover but I used
to be a just do acting as well and so I
can have more of that background but I I
think the thing I would like to do with
both at different points on me like I
like both but I don't necessarily like
doing both at the same time it's been
kind of a challenge to try to be in
front of the camera but that also be
thinking about what needs to happen
behind the camera especially in a
documentary a setting you know you're
you're trying to capture things as they
happen and it's so it's hard to
participate the things that are
happening and then try to capture me
same time because you're never
completely you know able to do both one
hundred percent and and so yeah I mean I
think I did say I don't know yes sure
and the emotion of building a home I
mean it's a rollercoaster ride because
things don't go well and then I don't
know how much you want to show up at on
camera oh but yeah I'm sure that's
that's tough because it is a very
emotional there's money involved right
things that dunkle so you know and when
when the emotion kicks in you're like
you're like oh I just broke that thing
really turn the camera off how am I
gonna do this you know instead of like
having the camera rolling you know so
that that was the struggle constantly is
just trying to get everything and then
also you know the things that you want
to get most are the hardest to capture
because you know they're you're in the
emotion it's hard to have the
perspective to think about capturing it
from the outside right exactly
you